greetings to all of you from pakistan it
is often said that we fear that which we
do not know
and
pakistan in this particular vein is very
similar because it has provoked and does
provoke a
visceral anxiety in the bellies of many
a western soul especially when viewed
through the monochromatic lens of
turbulence and turmoil but there are
many other dimensions to pakistan and
what follows is a stream of images a
series of images captured by some of
pakistan's most dynamic and young
photographers that aims to give you an
alternative glimpse a look inside the
hearts and minds of some ordinary
pakistani citizens here are some of the
stories they wanted us to share with you
my name is abdul khan i come from
peshawar i hope that you will be able to
see not just my taliban-like beard but
also the richness and color of my
perceptions aspirations and dreams as
rich and colorful as the satchels that i
sell
my name is maher and this is my friend
iram
i hope to become a vet when i grow up so
that i can take care of stray cats and
dogs who wander around the streets of
the village that i live in near gilgit
northern pakistan
my name is gailash and i like to enrich
lives through technicolored glass
madam would you like some of those
orange bangles with the pink polka dots
my name is zamin and i'm an idp an
internally displaced person from swath
do you see me on the other side of this
fence
do i matter or really exist for you
my name is iman i am a fashion model an
up-and-coming model from lahar do you
see me simply smothered in cloth or can
you move beyond my veil and see me for
who i truly am inside
my name is ahmad i am refugee from the
khabar agency
i have come from a place of intense
darkness and that is why i want to
illuminate the world
my name is papu say my heart and drum
beat is one
if religion is the opium of the masses
then for me music is my one and only
ganja
a rising tide lifts all boats and
the rising tide of india's spectacular
economic growth has lifted over 400
million
indians into a buoyant middle class but
there are still over 650 million indians
pakistanis sri lankans bangladeshis
nepalis who remain washed up on the
shores of poverty
therefore as india and pakistan as you
and i it behooves us to transcend our
differences to
celebrate our diversity to leverage our
common humanity
our collective vision at neya juven
which for many of you as you will
recognize means new life in urdu and
hindi is to rejuvenate the lives of
millions of low-income families by
providing them with affordable access to
catastrophic health care
indeed it is the emerging world's first
urban
hmo for the urban working poor
why should we do this as indians in
pakistanis we are but two threads cut
from the same cloth
and if we if our fates are intertwined
then we believe that it is good karma it
is good fortune and for many of us our
fortunes do indeed lie at the bottom of
the pyramid thank you
you stay at me that was fantastic
i found that really moving
you know
we fought hard to get at least
a small pakistani contingent to calm it
it was felt like it was really important
they went through a lot to
get here with the pakistanis please just
stand up please i just really want to
acknowledge
thank you so much
you